he ended up getting plenty of hype
during the season justin jefferson one
of the breakout stars last year for the
minnesota vikings so
this year chris has gone into the lab
he's studied the film with his ron
jaworski glasses and he has emerged with
this list of his six top receivers two
from lsu
two from alabama impressive group of
guys you were talking about them earlier
when i was experiencing technical
difficulties right here chris
just just as we look at that list of six
where do you draw the line between and
there went the list of six where do you
draw the line between the top tier and
the second tier of your six guys i think
the top three i look at to me and i
think they're in their own their own
class i like jalen waddle a lot again
like i tried to describe when we were
having the technical difficulties he's
more of a true slot wide receiver you
know when you talk about jamar chase
devonte smith to yami brown you could
say hey go line up on the outside all
day anytime you got one-on-one we'll
probably throw it to you but you know
plain and simple they got the size the
speed the strength all of those things
to do that so to me the top three are in
a little bit of a tier of their own
waddle is awesome but it's gonna be
about
hey you know
we need a slot guy or we need a guy that
can do that type of stuff his game is
more about route running and quick
twitch and all that he's plenty of
explosive too don't get me wrong but
he's a little bit of a smaller guy and
then the number five on that list
cadarius tony is is a weapon guy who
maybe needs a little more polish as a
wide receiver but has some physical
attributes that are really really
special i think all six of those guys
are first-round talents i do i could
maybe see the lsu guy terrace marshall
falling out of the first round maybe um
but even after that mike there's a few
like i say hollywood brown type-ish
players
that i think are very special too this
kid from north texas tyler uh
jordan i'm gonna mess up his name tutu
atwell from the louisville cardinals you
know where it's like they're really
small guys at five nine 170 mike but can
fly and i i also sit there and wonder
and go man i don't know i mean they're
if hollywood brown can go in the top 20.
why can't they go in the first round um
but it's it's a talented group
nonetheless
you're higher on dearmi brown than most
you're lower on jalen waddle than most
people are going to look at that and say
what gives so what gives well you know i
think that what i just you kind of heard
me say about waddle i i again like his
game but to me it's more
slot oriented i think if you had to live
and you were playing a 21 personnel
right two backs one tight end and it's
two receivers and you're playing like
the minnesota viking style of football
right
i don't know if i would like jaylen
waddle on the outside against bigger and
the best corners in football play after
play after play so that's where i i i
always favor the guy who's the stud
outside receiver and diami brown to me
was the
like the surprise right he was the guy
that you know i turned i went whoa why
like justin jefferson last year i want
to go why is nobody talking about this
guy i mean all he does is run by people
big plays it's speed speed speed and
speed i mean that's what it is it's it's
like you know a little bit odell beckham
jr-ish with how he reminds me how he
takes off from the line of scrimmage and
does that uh you know when odell was
coming out of college but he's a really
good route runner and for a route runner
that's a speed track guy there's a
physicality to his game there is he can
play through contact down the field
people pushing him doing all these
things he still catches the ball 50 50
ball catches the ball he's not some like
you know soft track guy who goes over
the middle and slides to the ground too
because he doesn't want contact he
lowers his shoulder the army brown to me
was the shocker of everybody i don't
know why i didn't hear more about him
he's a game breaker he's a superstar to
me and like when i watch him compared to
ruggs and jerry judy last year who won
the i just go
i would take this guy all day over them
this guy is a top 20 pick and i would
think he'd run four three something
maybe even high four twos if he got a
chance to run a 40 at the combine this
year or something like that
why chase over smith at the very top
it's close it's really close i just
chase has still a little room to grow as
a pure route runner but i think there's
just nothing negative about jamar chase
you know he can do
he he he's got first off a you know
elite speed just like we're going to
talk about with diamond brown or like
we'll talk about with devante but he can
run by anybody you know and even for not
being like the biggest guy in the world
he's just six foot he plays bigger than
that so he does a great job and these
top three guys where i go you know we
call them 50 50 balls they're not 50 50
balls with these guys they're 70 30
balls with these type of guys chase is
really good that way and why i put chase
number one to
outside slot availability but i think
he's the most
chase is the most special with the ball
in his hand when he gets the ball in his
hand
he is like a legit running back out in
space yeah he can run run by you with
pure speed he can break your ankles in
in space and make you look silly but he
also can break tackles and do stuff like
that he has a fearlessness about his
game when he gets the ball in his hands
and i think that's why i make him number
one but i don't think the gap is huge
between him and then devonta smith and
d'ami brown i mean i don't i'm i'm in
love with devonta smith i mean i did
think about ooh
should i make devonte smith one that was
a pleasant surprise when i watched his
game as well
smith spoke yesterday about what he
hopes to accomplish at his pro day
workout at which he will not be doing
any drills here he is
well i won't i won't be doing anything
at pro day but
just weighing in and things like that
just letting everybody just
get my weight
and what was that weight devonte if i
could just follow up quickly
why 70.
so that's it he's going to walk in he's
going to step on the scale he's going to
drop the mic and he's going to walk off
and hey
yeah good for him i have no prob i have
no problem with any of that the haze in
the barn go watch my film i'm not here
to entertain you i'm not here look if
you if you like me draft me if you don't
someone that you play maybe twice per
year will i love that attitude it's
about business it's about business it's
allowed to be about business for
everybody else except the players yeah
because we must be entertained so i got
no problem with that i don't care that
he's 170 pounds
i don't care as long as long as he can
get off the line of scrimmage and i
think when
when you're that
shifty when you're that fast it doesn't
matter if you have a guy right in your
face you're going to find a way to get
away from him agreed first off
he's setting the bar low
he's not going to weigh 170.
he's not i can just tell by the way he
answered that question i could tell by
the way he looks in his sweatshirt right
there yeah i'm a professional body
watcher okay he does not weigh 170. i'm
telling you he probably said that to set
the bar low and he's going to walk in
there and one why he's not doing the
drills either because he probably looks
at it and goes all right i'm going to
make it more about my weight and i might
be a hair slower than i want to be and
do those type of things i bet you he
comes in more than 180 that's what i'm
gonna throw out there we'll see if i'm
right and hopefully we can remember to
do that but
like mike you said it right you know
okay yeah there's the concerns about
like he's 6-1 he's 170 or 175. all right
so let me turn on the film and watch him
just get beat up then because he's just
a weak skinny wimp oh that's right it
doesn't ever happen it doesn't ever
happen you know so it i'd be worried
about it if i saw something to justify
that on film but there's nothing to
justify that in the sec where by far has
the most pro nfl corners
and you know you talk about like the
quick fee and all that yes he's
incredibly quick at the line of
scrimmage and then his speed is scary
you know it's like it's like dearmi
brown from north carolina where it's
like they shake you with the line of
scrimmage they do a great job of getting
into a jump cut position where like both
feet are equal so now they can go either
way the db doesn't have a tail you got a
base underneath you so you can't get
pushed off balance with your feet being
cock-eyed right that makes sense and
then they explode up field and smith is
like he's he flies it's three steps and
you better watch out or he's gonna run
by you and with that aspect too
that scares people from jamming them all
to be to begin with anyways because most
dbs they want to act like they're down
there and bump and run but as soon as
they say said hut they're going whoa i
gotta get back because he might run by
me and you know there's nothing in his
game that doesn't show physicality he's
a better route runner he's tougher than
i was expected
man is the explosive as hell
he can catch the ball and turn up
like a sixth sense like jamar chase uh
mike and i know i'm talking too long
here but he catches the ball and they
have like a great feel of where the guys
are behind them to where they catch it
and turn up all in like one thing and
you go well that was a 10-yard
completion but it became a 20-yard
completion because he was already
running up field when he had that when
he was in the process of catching the
ball and got up field so quick so i'm a
huge davonte smith man and nothing says
that his weight's going to be a problem
one of your most impressive skills
is to have the self-awareness
that you're talking too long
admit it and still go and still keep
talking that's impressive thank you let
me say this about devonta smith because
i agree with your take here what does he
need to do at his pro day who cares
about his drills who cares about any of
that all anyone cares about is how much
he weighs so show up shock the world
walk off and chris wouldn't it be great
if our job for a two or three month
period if all we had to do somebody came
to us and said what do we need to do to
enhance our our status in whatever
whatever the field is oh you just got to
gain about 10 pounds hell i'd sign up
for that right now i get it done by the
end of the week
pizza milkshake candy more milkshake
more pizza ice cream i'd get to ten
pounds i'll tell you i could gain 10
pounds by tomorrow if i had to oh mike
let me just say that's one of the best
parts of being an athlete really and you
know
i mean you're right he first off if
jamar chase is gonna be the number one
receiver and we're gonna go wait he
didn't even play football last year
and you're gonna dock me because i don't
do a workout you know then like yeah
screw you get all i don't want to be on
your team anyways so what that's great
he did all this stuff on film and
dominated which is probably the toughest
schedule in the history of college
football that alabama played in all scc
schedule there was no like you know
schools of the northwest south
northeastern dakota state they didn't
play any of those schools so that was
rough you mean like byu well yeah some
of those right but but but but here's
the other thing i want to just like with
the the eating thing man mike before
training camp every year on a personal
level you know i knew we were going down
to orlando wild world of sports there it
was going to be 98 degrees and 100
humidity you don't know it doesn't
matter what you go in weighing you're
gonna lose eight or ten pounds that
first week of football practice i used
to eat everything underneath the sun two
weeks leading up to the training camp my
wife would make me toast and jelly in
the morning and have half a stick of
butter on there you know as i actually
threw the jelly on and i ate a pack of
bacon on top of it it was the best and i
didn't have to think about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports